hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
one of the key ideas in milton
friedman's essay the social
responsibility of business is to
increase its profits is right there in
the title its responsibilities
so
he's going to clarify for us
who in fact can have responsibilities in
part because as he says this this word
social responsibility seems to be a
rather
vague term he says the discussions of
the social responsibilities of business
are notable for their analytic looseness
and lack of rigor so he's saying to us
that we need to clarify
who actually can have responsibilities
and
what sort of responsibilities they have
and then who those responsibilities are
are owed to you could say or directed
towards and if we do that then we can
see
how we ought to view any sort of
advocation
or
enactment of social responsibilities in
terms of business so who in fact can
have
responsibilities
friedman is going to consider a number
of different cases the the one that's
paradigm for this essay is the corporate
executive or as he's going to call him a
little bit later the manager so we'll
come back to that one in just a moment
because it's so absolutely central but a
little bit later in the piece he
actually talks about two other
groups that might have some sort of
stake
actually they have more of a stake in
some sense than the corporate executive
because they own either part or the
entirety
of the company so he he talks about the
case of stockholders and he says that
the same argument that he's making
applies to the newer phenomenon of
calling upon stockholders to require
corporations to exercise social
responsibility there he's talking about
stockholder
advocacy
of
you know divesting from certain things
or directing the products in a certain
way
or insisting that a certain wage be paid
to employees or benefits we could go on
and on about examples but it's been a
phenomenon where some of the
stockholders would attempt to try to
steer a corporation
in a particular direction and they may
in fact buy stock precisely so that they
can do that he also talks about the
individual proprietor and here
friedman says there really isn't any
problem he says the situation of the
individual proprietor is somewhat
different if he acts to reduce the
returns of his enterprise in order to
exercise his social responsibility he is
spending his own money not someone
else's so that that's really the key for
friedman friedman thinks that there's no
problem spending your own money if it
truly is your own money on all sorts of
socially beneficial
aims and we're going to talk about what
what's his examples of those are in just
a moment
if you want to create a charity to do
something and you're using your
individual proprietor business to do so
not a problem
he also briefly discusses unions and he
says that social responsibility is
something that the unions themselves
reject when it's being used to justify
wage restraint he says that when union
officials are asked to subordinate the
interest of their members to some more
general purpose they
generally say no we're not going to do
that so that's another example that
would apply here but let's come back now
to the corporate executive so the
corporate executive is somebody who's in
a different sort of position than the
individual proprietor it's not their
company and they have to take the assets
and the
goodwill and all the other resources
that the company has it's cash flow
whatever you want to call that and
decide how to allocate those things how
to run the business and so friedman says
that
when he says that that a person can have
responsibilities but their
responsibility
is to the owners of the business he says
he has direct responsibility to his
employers and what is that
responsibility
the responsibility is to conduct the
business in accordance with their
desires
what are their desires friedman goes on
and says these generally will be to make
as much money as possible while
conforming to their basic rules of the
society those embodied in law those
embodied in ethical custom he does hold
out the possibility that there could be
some other purposes that the owners have
he talks about this is coming from the
greek term eleos meaning pity or
compassion and allow
allow mercenary purpose right and he
gives examples of those as hospitals or
schools so if i establish a school
and i hire somebody to be the the dean
of that school and manage it
that would be an example where i'm the
one who's directing the purpose and the
dean still has to run it like a business
in order to maintain that institution in
general for most corporations or most
institutions the goal is going to be to
make money the goal is going to be to do
what the owners wanted to do so the
corporate executive has a responsibility
to run things in such a way as to try to
maximize profits
now he also points out
that the
corporate executive him or herself
can be as he says a person in their own
right and he says as a person he may
have many other responsibilities that he
or she assumes or recognizes voluntarily
to family conscience feelings of charity
clubs churches city country and so that
person can take part of their income if
they want the
salary that the company is paying them
their bonuses whatever
and devoted to those aims but they don't
have the right
according to freedmen to divert company
resources to serving those aims they
can't pick their favorite charity to be
the recipient of the company's largesse
that would actually be violating the
obligation to the stockholders or the
owners
what about corporations themselves
friedman says that a corporation is an
artificial person so it can have at most
artificial responsibilities when it
comes to talking about business with
sort of a capital b as something that
you know runs throughout society says
there is no responsibility on the part
of business as such only corporations or
individuals can have responsibilities an
entire sector of the economy cannot
so who are these responsibilities
directed towards then and notice that
friedman does not just talk about these
stockholders owners or as he's going to
say the employers a little bit later
when he's when he's describing the bad
effects as he takes it of diverting any
sort of resources or making decisions on
the basis of social responsibility
he will tell us that it's not only
employers who are being given you know
short shrift but also customers why
customers because
if you are not making the business as
lean as possible as profitable as
possible then you're going to have to
raise prices for the customers also
employees
if you're going to
use the business or structure the
business or direct it in such a way that
it's being less efficient that means
that you can't pay the
employees as much according to friedman
and it gives several examples of this
and the examples are quite interesting
notice this of course is a piece from
1970 so these are examples that fit
particularly well with those times the
first one is he says uh dealing with
inflation he may re uh
you know we might refrain from
increasing the price of a product in
order to contribute to the social
objective of preventing inflation even
though a price increase would be in the
best interest of the corporation big
problem in the 1970s big worry so there
was a lot of pressure not to raise your
prices another example would be
pollution
he says
here we go
one might make expenditures on reducing
pollution beyond the amount that is in
the best interest of the corporation or
what is required by law in order to
contribute to the social objective of
improving the environment the third one
that he gives has to do with
unemployment and here he talks about the
hardcore unemployed these are the people
who have been chronically unemployed
usually because they lack job skills or
knowledge or because there are certain
behavioral problems that need to be
dealt with and you know some businesses
might hire those people anyway even
though they're not good employees
precisely because it's a social
responsibility
of the business or that's the way the
manager views it now what is the problem
with this friedman says that when you do
this
you are affecting all these other people
in each of these cases he says the
corporate executive would be spending
someone else's money who are the someone
else's employers
customers employees
he says in so far as his actions
in accord with his social responsibility
reduced returns to stockholders he's
spending their money
in as his actions raise the price to
customers he's spending customers money
insofar as his actions lower the wages
of some employees he is spending their
money and that is what in friedman's
view is wrong with following social
responsibility if you are indeed a
corporate executive making decisions so
he says that
the executive is exercising a distinct
social responsibility rather than doing
what they're supposed to be
serving as an agent of the stockholders
or customers or employees why because he
spends the money in a different way than
they would have spent it and he says
this amounts in in effect to a tax
on
on each of these
groups or individuals and friedman views
that as an abdication of the genuine
responsibility that someone has so in
ethical terms it's something wrong
you